and I think we can now be fairly
confident that we have a pretty good
model of kind of how fundamental physics
Works How the Universe kind of works all
the way down so let me talk a little bit
about that if I can find a good picture
for that
um
uh let's see so what what is our
universe made of
it's um you know back
in the 1800s people were still wondering
what's Mata made of and there was this
crazy idea that matter is made of
molecules nobody knew that was correct
until sometime after 1900 when things
like Brownian motion were understood and
so on but people kind of thought well
maybe maybe matter is is made of
discreet things then people thought
maybe their electromagnetic field is
made of discrete things photons that
turned out to be true but space people
always assumed like Euclid had assumed
that space is a continuous thing where
space is just this background and you
put things at certain places in space
you're specifying positions but there's
space isn't made of anything space is
just just a background that you put
things in so the kind of starting point
for our model of physics is that that's
not true that space is actually made of
things space is made of atoms of space
um that there are discrete elements
which whose only feature is that they
exist and they are distinct from other
discrete elements these are the we
sometimes call them atoms of space
sometimes more generally we call them
Eames eme and
the idea is that the whole structure of
the universe consists of just this whole
collection of atoms of space maybe 10 to
the 400 of them in our current universe
and the only thing one can say about
these atoms of space is how they're
related to each other so one can one
defines a collection of relations
between atoms of space someone can
represent those relations by a graph or
more generally a hypograph where in a
graph for example you have two nodes in
the graph and two those two nodes are
related and that's indicated by the
presence of an edge in the graph so
you end up with uh so you imagine that
everything in the universe is just this
giant hypergraph hypergraph just has can
have more than two things related in on
a hyper Edge instead of just a two two
things on an ordinary edge and a graph
you'd have any number of things on a
hyper edge and a hypergraph
so
we imagine the whole universe is just
made of this hypograph and everything
that we experience all of the electrons
and photons and things like that
everything gravity all those kinds of
things those are all just features of
this hypergraph
so
one question and then the and that's
that's kind of the there's nothing in
the universe except space and features
of space
and the idea is that time for example
enters in a very different way than
space in this model
um and the way time enters is as kind of
a sequence of updates that happen so you
say you have a typograph that looks like
this every time you see a little piece
of hypergraph that looks like that
rewrite it to this and you just keep
doing that over and over again a bit
like in that cellular automaton except
in the cellular automaton we have this
kind of rigid array of cells here we
just have this floppy hyper graph and
it's getting updated lots and lots of
times
well so the question is when you just do
that you take this typograph you update
it lots and lots of times what is the
end result what do you get in the end
well the uh what you know from for
example uh physics of I don't know uh
something like a gas you have all these
molecules they're all bouncing around
there are lots of details there's a lot
of complicated detail in how these
molecules bounce around but in the end
what we at our scale what we experience
is just the Continuum dynamics of a
fluid a gas for example so in the case
of molecular Dynamics the limit of all
these all these microscopic things on a
large scale is the equations of fluid
dynamics and things like that okay so
what happens if you take one of these
typographs and you look at the limits on
a large scale of all of the uh discrete
rewritings that happen there turns out
that the corresponding thing to the
fluid equations is the Einstein
equations for space time so in other
words on a large scale it is inevitably
the case that with various footnotes
which are complicated
it's it's basically inevitably the case
that the large-scale limit of all of
those detailed rewritings will give you
something which corresponds to what we
know about the structure of space-time
so it's not even obvious that the
hypergraph you get will be any
particular number of dimensional space a
hypograph doesn't have any particular
Dimension but you can start asking if
you start at a given point in the
hypergraph you just expand you go to
things that are some number of graph
distances away how many how many things
will you get to when you can start
estimating Dimensions you can estimate
curvatures things like that but the main
point is that just by looking at this
kind of microscopic rewriting of this
hypergraph we get something which
corresponds to the known structure of
space-time